madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
de l'actualité de ce vendredi
le prix du gazole à la pompe plus cher
que l'essence c'est un constat que vous
allez pouvoir faire très vite dans le
sillage de la flambée du prix du pétrole
le carburant le plus consommé de france
fait un nouveau bond nous verrons
pourquoi dans un instant comment
protéger nos enfants des dérives des
nouvelles technologies et notamment de
l'accès à la pornographie via internet
ou même sur et de téléphones portables
une affaire en région parisienne
impliquant des enfants de 11 et 12 ans
dans un violent relance la question
le ton monte ce soir dans la campagne
américaine barack obama vient de
qualifier d' attaques malhonnêtes les
propos tenus par le clan républicain
ce sont en fait les déclarations du
président bush qui sont à l'origine de
cette tension
il avait affirmé que le démocrate avait
une attitude conciliante avec les
terroristes
la tête et les jambes le championnat de
france de football se jouera demain sur
quelques détails qui supportera le mieux
la pression lyon et bordeaux se prépare
idem pour ceux qui luttent pour le
maintien
nous ferons point sur ses dernières 90
minutes de ligue 1 enfin nous irons à
cannes la fin ce journal avec
l'événement du jour un film français en
compétition film d'arnaud desplechin le
titre un conte de noël avec nous ce soir
catherine deneuve et mathieu amalric
deux des acteurs de cette histoire de
famille c'est le nouveau record du jour
le baril de pétrole a cette fois dépassé
à new york les 127 dollars un chiffre
qui conduit invariablement les
carburants à la hausse
le fuel l'essence et bien sûr le gazole
sont concernés et selon les derniers
relevés à la pompe le prix du gazole a
commencé à dépasser parfois le prix de
l'essence
alors pourquoi cette hausse plus rapide
tout cela est dû un reg à une règle
économique simple la loi de l'offre et
de la demande explications se fit brune
et fabien delory dans cette station
service donnant la hiérarchie
traditionnelle des prix s'est inversée
depuis hier le gazole a dépassé les sens
un neuro 43 contre 1,42
assez dépassé quand même je ne savais
pas
ah oui c'est énorme bon ben c'est le
portefeuille qui vont à prendre un coup
c'est impressionnant et assez peu biaisé
l'histoire passée devant les sens déjà
que c'est cher mais alors maintenant en
fait le gazole a toujours été plus cher
à produire que les sens mais il est
moins taxé ce qui jusqu'à présent
expliqué son prix inférieur à l'ap hm
aujourd'hui la très forte demande
inverse la tendance et dernière la
demande de gazole a augmenté de 3% alors
que la demande en essence chutait de
près de 5%
et c'est cette consommation de gazole
sans cesse croissante qui fait qu'à une
tension très particulière sur le prix du
gazole qui fait monter les prix
résultat le prix hors taxe du gazole
augmente depuis plusieurs mois plus vite
que celui de l'essence du coup
l'avantagé fiscal du diesel disparaît
malgré ce rattrapage les
concessionnaires continuent de
recommander les véhicules diesel dans
certains cas ça reste quand même pour
l'instant encore intéressant pour les
personnes qui font pour les gros
rouleurs dans la mesure où le diesel en
termes de consommation reste quand même
inférieur aux véhicules essence le
gazole plus cher que l'essence la
tendance pourrait se généraliser car en
france les trois quarts des voitures ont
un moteur diesel et plusieurs profession
souffre de cette hausse des carburants
ainsi la fronde se poursuit chez les
marins pêcheurs après le mouvement des
sables d'olonne
c'est le port de la rochelle qui est
désormais bloqué les pêcheurs réclament
toujours un soutien financier du
gouvernement pour compenser cette
augmentation continue du carburant ils
en seront plus mercredi leur ministre de
tutelle michel barnier recevra les
représentants de la la semaine prochaine
un retour maintenant sur les intempéries
qui se sont déroulées hier soir dans le
nord et le sud du pays tout d'abord
direction toulouse là bas c'est un
violent orage de grêle qui s'est abattu
sur la ville images étonnantes signée
olivier combe et commenter sur place par
antoine gaveau
un déluge de grêle une pluie de glaçons
de plusieurs centimètres de diamètre il
est 21h hier soir et apparemment le ciel
tombe sur la tête des toulousains
l'orage très violent ne dure qu'une demi
heure assez pour prendre au piège les
automobilistes et transformer la ville
rose en une gigantesque et blanches
patinoire et a beaucoup diraient de pied
tombé ça passait en dessous des portes
et voilà c'est la galère jamais vu ça by
centimètres de glace sur les trottoirs
et des litres d'eau en sous sol
plusieurs stations de métro doivent être
fermés dans la nuit les pompiers
effectueront plus de 300 interventions
comme dans ce restaurant où le plafond
s'effondre sur les clients en plein
repas c'est de l'eau ya pas mort d'homme
ya pas mort d'homme êtes en train de
manger à table vous prenez 20 litres
d'eau sur la tête
aujourd'hui des dizaines de bâtiments
offre le même spectacle les pieds dans
l'eau et les plafonds par terre les
intempéries n'ont fait aucune victime
mais les dégâts matériels sont lourds 30
écoles élémentaires comme celles ci ont
subi des dommages
par sécurité plusieurs ont dû fermer
leurs portes pour la journée
météo france avait identifié un risque
orageux mais sans gravité particulière
donc ça sa violence et son caractère
très localisées ont été une surprise
la ville devrait sous peu être classés
en état de catastrophe naturelle
l'ampleur des dégâts n'a pas encore été
estimé et puis dans le nord pas de
calais de fortes pluies orageuses ont
éclaté hier en fin de journée plusieurs
axes routiers ont été totalement bloqué
notamment près de lille
certains conducteurs ont dû tout
simplement abandonner leur véhicule sur
l'autoroute nombreuses innovations
également dans la région béthune dans le
pas de calais
que faut-il penser de cette affaire
maintenant s'agit-il de mimétisme en
tout cas les faits sont plus que
troublants je vous en parlais en titre
deux enfants de 11 et 12 ans après avoir
regardé un film pornographique ont
reproduit les scènes qu'ils avaient vu
avec la soeur de l'un d'eux une petite
fille de dix ans l'affairé
révélée parce que les deux garçons
avaient filmé les faits et les faisait
visionner sur leur téléphone au collège
arnaut goûter yann richard c'est un
village huppé
un bourg tranquille ou la pornographie
vient d'ouvrir la porte de la violence
cette fois juvénile le drame par d'une
négligence parentale
il y a une semaine un garçon de 11 ans
invite chez lui son copain de 12 ans
accompagné de sa petite soeur et trois
enfants parviennent à visionner un film
pornographique
les garçons vont ensuite tenter de
reproduire les scènes il viole la
fillette de 10 ans est filmé à l'aide
d'un portable
la vidéo va faire le tour du collège
comment tu as eu connaissance de la
vidéo des gens qui me l'ont dit celle-ci
diffuser rapidement rapidement quelques
jours était camarades qu'est ce qu'ils
en pensent
vous en parlez entre vous pas tellement
les deux garçons de 6e ont été mises en
examen et placées en famille d'accueil
devant l'établissement les parents
d'élèves cherche les mots comment
expliquer l'inexplicable
ils ont quand même vu des choses qu'ils
n'auraient jamais dû voir et qu'ils
n'ont pas le recul nécessaire pour
arriver à faire la part des choses quoi
entre la fiction et ce qu'il est
possible de faire dans la réalité et ses
trois vies gâchées des parents là
l'aspect ctions d'académie veut lancer
une campagne pour prévenir des dangers
de l'internet et des vidéos violentes
bref il faut s'adapter la société a
changé les enfants changent et les
parents changer tout changer et donc il
est nécessaire que le système éducatif
évoluent les supports pédagogiques
évoque déjà les violences sexuelles
mais cela ne suffit pas ou part du
principe que du vent juste
tu ne fonctionne qu'une responsabilité
dans ce genre de des changes
ils ont devoir de contrôle des coûts ce
que contient un ordinateur ou
éventuellement un téléphone portable
les deux garçons seront renvoyés devant
un juge pour enfants et compte tenu de
leur âge ils ne feront pas l'objet d'une
sanction pénale la justice avec les
suites du procès de michel fourniret
devant les assises des ardennes avec la
nouvelle volte face de l'accusé qui a à
nouveau décidé de se taire ne souhaitant
plus s'exprimer sur les faits une
attitude condamnée par les parties
civiles qui en signe de protestation ont
déserté symboliquement les bancs du
tribunal durant plus d'une heure
aujourd'hui la brigade criminelle de
paris est en charge de l'enquêté sur
l'explosion d'un bar à orly dans le val
de marne explosion dans la nuit de
mercredi à jeudi qui a fait un mort et
une blessée grave le gérant
l'établissement et sa mère celle-ci
s'était rendu sur place alors que son
fils l'avait appelé pour lui dire qu'il
était séquestrée
pierre monnet gier marque de langue à
nagano la porte du bar a été projeté à
une trentaine de mètres
il ne reste presque plus rien de ce qu'a
fait d'orly dans le val de marne
l'établissement a été soufflé par une
violente déflagration jeudi vers 1h du
matin jean tandis que les explosions
parce que ça se fait complètement chez
nous c'est quand j'ai su me parle à
peine quand la vie vraiment tout et
enclenche quoi en flammes à l'intérieur
le nouveau gérant samir giguère 20 ans
juste avant l'explosion il téléphone à
sa mère
pour lui dire qu'il était séquestrée
dans le bas-rhin grey's individuel
ouvert des bouteilles de gaz et tenter
d'y mettre le feu
pour ce qui est apparemment avérées sa
maman s'est présenté sur place et au
moment où elle arrivait le bar a explosé
mon cal a été gravement blessée elle est
aujourd'hui dans un état critique
son fils est mort sur le coup quel peut
être le mobile de cet attentat
cambriolages à répétition dégradations
menaces de mort samir giguère se disait
la cible d'une bande du quartier
une hypothèse revient il tentait
d'éloigner de son bar des trafiquants de
drogue
à mots couverts les voisins
confirme-t-il 7 et aliéné une partie de
la cité y avait des relations difficiles
avec le g20 c'est normal qu'on a c'est
quoi c'est à dire que le plaignant
disait que ces jeunes et a merdé lui
avait peut-être des rapports beaucoup
plus psychologiquement musclé on va dire
parce que elle était coach ne sait pas
faire
pour l'instant les enquêteurs tentent
surtout de collecter un maximum
d'éléments matériels sur les lieux de
l'explosion
et notamment sur la nature de la bombe
utilisée
l'ancien entraîneur de laure manaudou a
été aujourd'hui mise en examen philippe
lucas est soupçonné de malversations
financières on parle de vol et d' usage
de chèques falsifiés
les faits qui lui sont reprochés
remontent à l'époque où il était
entraîneur au sein du cercle des nageurs
de melun
christelle bertrand claire marie denis
entraîneur atypique au look original
philippe lucas nage aujourd'hui en eaux
troubles
il est soupçonné d'avoir encaissé 25
mille euros à l'époque où il était
entraîneur de laure manaudou à melun en
région parisienne le club lui reproche
d'avoir falsifié ces chèques pour moi
c'est l'étape essentielle ce qui prouve
que notre plainte était fondée n'était
pas du tout fantaisiste il va falloir
que ceux qui ont participé justement à
ces malversations paye et paye
suffisamment qui pleuvent
les enquêteurs ont épluché les comptes
du club 1 pour la période 2001 2006 dans
cette affaire laure manaudou a aussi été
entendu
la nageuse aurait touché un chèque
litigieux de 20000 euros le procureur a
mis la championne hors de cause
philippe lucas lui a été mis en examen
ce soir son avocat crie au complot
la mise en examen pour vol usage de
chèques falsifiés abus de confiance et
l'expression judiciaire de règlements de
comptes au sein de l'association
aujourd'hui à melun la piscine
porte le nom de la nageuse n'accueille
plus de sportifs de haut niveau
cette affaire entache l'image du club
qui traverse une mauvaise passe
financière la politique nicolas sarkozy
en marge d'un déplacement à
dammarie-les-lys concernant la fusion
unedic anpe a réaffirmé sa volonté de
mettre en place un service d'accueil
dans les écoles fermées en cas de grève
le projet à ces dernières heures suscité
de nombreuses critiques côté syndicats
mais également de la part du parti
socialiste françois hollande affirmant
que ce projet était inconstitutionnelle
on écoute ce soir le chef de l'état et
le point de vue sur la question de
ségolène royal parler de la
constitutionnalité c'est vraiment une
curieuse conception aussi alice public
tout du droit d'accueil
comment mais comment font les gens et
femmes travaillent
l'homme travaille alors quand les deux
parents travaillent on n'a pas une garde
à domicile
comment font les gens
j'ai pensé aujourd'hui à des coupes
sombres dans l'éducation nationale il ya
un mépris des enseignants il ya des
décisions qui sont mal préparés qu'ils
ne sont pas négociés et moi ce que je
demande à nicolas sarkozy c'est de
réformer le pays en respectant les gens
en faisant en sorte que l'intérêt
général l'emportent toujours et partout
et c'est parce qu'il y aura de bonnes
réformes et qu'il n'y aura pas de grève
et donc il sera inutile de faire de la
provocation
la ministre de l'économie christine
lagarde a annoncé aujourd'hui une
révision à la hausse des chiffres de la
création d'emplois salariés en france
des chiffres positifs certes mais qui
sont toujours très éloignés de ceux
enregistrés vous allez le voir en
norvège là bas le taux de chômage fait
rêver il est de 1,6 pour cent de la
population active et certains français
ont d'ailleurs été tenté par l'aventuré
reportage sur place
julien beaumont et didier dans si le
dernier lieu à la mode
à oslo une boulangerie d'ailleurs pour
pascal goulignac les affaires vont si
bien qu'avec son frère il pense ouvrir
un autre point de vente
le cinquième en deux ans seul problème
les employés pascal fait partie des 40 %
de patrons norvégien qui peinent à
trouver de la main d'oeuvre qualifiée et
c'est en norvège tout se joue dans
l'eure où dans les deux heures il ya
vous recevez un cv c'est à une annonce
afin de le serrer arriver il faut pas
trop rester devant
l'ordinateur regardez son éditeur tous
les quarts d'heure fond de cv a fait la
personne immédiatement des vendeuses
très demandé dans toute la ville quand
je suis arrivé à oslo j'ai trouvé cet
emploi en quoi deux semaines à peu près
donc c'est pas si compliqué vous savez
en ce moment il ya pas mal de boutiques
qui cherchait le monde
cinquième exportateur mondial de pétrole
la norvège profite du prix record du
baril résultat l'économie est en plein
boom
du coup à l'anpe locale on croise très
peu de chômeurs normal ils ne sont que
39 milles pour 5 millions d'habitants
ses 3000 de moins qu'en mars chaque mois
ici ce centre offre dix mille
propositions ça dans tous les secteurs
surtout dans le bâtiment où les ventes
où il ya beaucoup de demandes pour faire
face à cette demande
le pays ouvre ses frontières exemple sur
les chantiers on y trouve beaucoup de
polonais comme tomek il travaille ici
depuis trois ans 2000 euros net par mois
c'est quatre fois plus que chez lui en
ce moment les salaires sont moins
avantageux qu'il y a deux ans mais ça
reste quand même très intéressant c'est
ici que les immigrés viennent d'obtenir
leur permis de travail et pour eux le
gouvernement norvégien a facilité les
démarches pour un résident européen il
faut maintenant quelques jours là où
avant il fallait compter au minimum
trois mois
résultat la norvège n'a jamais autant
accueilli d'immigrés qu'en ce moment la
campagne américaine maintenant et le ton
monte entre républicains et démocrates à
l'origine de tout cela
une phrase prononcée par le président en
exercice george bush qui avait affirmé
jeudi lors de son voyage en israël que
les démocrates avaient une attitude
conciliante avec les terroristes
une attaque jugée aujourd'hui malhonnête
par barack obama sur place martin
laroche joubert
obama cible des républicains
aujourd'hui en campagne dans le dakota
du sud des primaires ils sont organisées
le 3 juin
il s'insurge contre les attaques de
faiblesse face au terrorisme
déjà accusé d'être le candidat du hamas
par john mc cain
il répond aux dernières critiques de
george bush
à la knesset pierre aux nonnains web le
jour de la célébration des 60 ans
d'israël dit-il george bush m'accuse moi
et les autres démocrates de négocier
avec les terroristes pour les apaiser
comme ce qui a apaisé adolf hitler
exactement le type d' attaque odieuse
qui a divisé notre pays nous aliéner le
monde
c'est pour ça qu'on a besoin de
changement hier à la knesset george bush
l'avait implicitement visée que nous
devrions négocier avec les terroristes
et les extrémistes comme si les
arguments agents mesurent civile est
persuadé qu'ils se trompent et de shilo
des beurs sénateur a déclaré ah si
j'avais pu parler à tort des attaques
relayées par john mc cain
pourquoi le sénateur obama vous qui
s'asseoir avec un état qui soutient le
terrorisme
c'est une grave erreur mais mme hillary
clinton a pris la défense d'obama
côté démocrate les accusations de george
bush ont provoqué un tollé
face à l'ampleur du drame que la chine
est en train de vie finalement les
autorités du pays ont décidé d'accepter
l'aide de pays étrangers
le japon la russie la corée du sud ont
donc envoyé sur place des équipes de
secours
cent trente mille soldats chinois
participent déjà en tout cas aux
recherches et désormais tout est une
question d'heures pour les éventuels
survivants
jérôme berlin de sa famille c'est tout
ce qu'il a retrouvé une photo de mariage
celle de son frère
c'est tout ce qu'il me reste les quatre
membres de leur famille sont morts on
tisse aussi est mort
il faisait sa sieste là-bas dans son
jardin d'enfants ici là qu'ils ont
enterré maintenant un cimetière géant
voilà ce qu'est devenu beichuan quand on
prend un peu d'auteurs on comprend le
sens de l'expression rayés de la carte
en route vers le centre-ville les
premiers camions de l'armée et de la
croix-rouge premiers sauveteurs
premières impressions st il ya tellement
de blessés ici et première intervention
ou 6 il mettait un garrot ici on soigne
un rescapé
ailleurs on en cherche d'autres emplois
dans quels cas là dedans ils viennent de
trouver une survivante le seyant
dépêchez vous il ya des cas ils seraient
bientôt d'ordre et y avait un bail a été
votre main devant vos yeux
merci merci
mais quatre jours après le séisme les
scènes comme celles ci vont devenir de
plus en plus rares une nouvelle réplique
ce matin 5,9 sur l'échelle de richter a
anéanti des routes des axes qui venait à
peine d'être rétabli pour certaines
zones
à l'arrivée des secours n'est pas pour
tout de suite
une autre plus gros problème c'est l'eau
potable
ici il n'ya plus des vieux et des
enfants personne d'assez fort pour
porter les gros jerrycans plus bas
l'armée est déjà débordé une urgence
sanitaire par centaines par milliers les
cadavres viennent s'entasser dans les
fosses communes pour ceux qui ont droit
à des obsèques en ville
le crématorium crache sa fumée nuitées
jour sur sa porte une inscription
la beauté est quelque part entre le ciel
et la terre
je vous le disais les autorités
chinoises ont donc revu leur position
sur l'aide logistique étrangères le
pouvoir de pékin qui avec ce drame
multiplie les interventions à la
télévision il souhaite afficher son
omniprésence sur le terrain et il
démontre en même temps sa parfaite
maîtrise de la communication en temps de
crise reportage de nos correspondants
pascal golomer et nicolas mauges et la
télévision l'a montré toute la journée
tel un général en campagne au jintao le
numéro un chinois s'est à son tour rendu
dans les régions sinistrées du se
tchouan aujourd'hui pour une tournée
d'inspection très médiatique
qu'on se le dise tous les chinois
jusqu'au puissants sont mobilisés la
télévision suit 24 heures sur 24
l'avancée des secours
et elle insiste bien plus sur le
dévouement des sauveteurs que sur la
détresse des survivants
ce sont les consignes données par le
gouvernement on salue aussi le
formidable élan de solidarité à travers
tout le pays
plus de 130 millions d'euros en argent
et en vivent ont déjà été collectés dans
ce collège du centre de pékin
comme dans des milliers d'autres écoles
chinoises les élèves se sont eux aussi
cotiser 17000 euros en deux jours les
élèves
ému par ce drame national qui se joue à
1500 km de la capitale
le séisme a touché une région assez
pauvre tous les efforts que les gens
avaient fait pour se développer ont été
détruits d'un seul coup et puis ces
morts et ces disparus les collectes de
sang elle aussi attiré la grande foule
ici on refuse du monde dès 10 heures du
matin il faut s'inscrire et revenir le
lendemain la croix rouge ne peut faire
face alors quand quelqu'un est dans la
détresse tout le monde à venir l'aider
c'est la tradition ici et moi en plus je
suis membre du parti communiste
c'est mon devoir d'apporter ma
contribution unie et solidaire c'est
l'image que la nation chinoise toute
entière veut donner d'elle-même face au
drame qui l'a frappé une chine unis
derrière ses dirigeants c'était en tout
cas le message qu'a martelé depuis trois
jours le régime
au nom de la sacro-sainte stabilité du
pays et autres catastrophes en asie
celle qui a touché la birmanie avec
soshy désormais annoncée par la
télévision d'état le bilan du cyclone
nargis s'élève à près de 78 morts et
cinquante six mille disparus
la france est en retard en ce qui
concerne l'accueil de diagnostic de
l'autisme
ce n'est pas nouveau cela fait des
années que les familles réclament plus
de moyens
c'est la raison pour laquelle un nouveau
plan a été lancé aujourd'hui par le
gouvernement objectif la création de
plus de 4000 nouvelle place et cela sur
cinq ans une annonce faite en présence
de la comédienne sandrine bonnaire qui
est très impliqué dans ce combat on
écoute sa réaction c'est vrai que 4000
places sur cinq ans a dit m
ainsi à la fois une goutte d'eau et puis
en même temps si c'est quand même
je dirais qu'il ya des gens très fat a
forcément sur le nombre mais un sur un
plan
de qualité un nouvel élan en tout cas
qui pourrait à terme permettre d'éviter
parfois aux familles de devoir quitter
l'hexagone de nombreux français se voit
ainsi obligé depuis des années à trouver
une solution d'accueil hors de nos
frontières exemple en belgique avec le
reportage d'elsa palau et de patrick dur
se remet toujours capter l'attention des
enfants pour les sortir de leur bulle
cette école spécialisée belge accueille
une trentaine d' autiste
arthur est scolarisé depuis deux ans et
demi pourtant il est français mais ici
ils bénéficient d'une toute autre prise
en charge
régis en france on le voit plus encore
en tant que enfants avec une difficulté
mentale et donc plus avec un besoin
médical qu'avec un besoins éducatifs
faute de place et de structures adaptées
3500 autistes français s'est il ainsi en
belgique pour compenser l'état français
verse parfois des aides aux
établissements mais pas toujours
alors dans l'école d'arthur c'est le
contribuable belge qui paie aujourd'hui
tout est gratuit chez doudou présent
fort riche aussi bien belges français
donc sonné manger un procès si ce n'est
bien sûr pas l'argent de la cantine mais
ce n'est pas l'argument financier qui a
décidé les parents d'arthur en france
leurs enfants étaient accueillis en
hôpital de jour
mais eux ou les autres choses ils ont
donc quitté l'alsace la famille le
travail la maison pour venir s'installer
à quelques kilomètres de la frontière
belge
tout près de l'école on aurait pu se
contenter de cette prise en charge en
hôpital de jour mais on voyait pas
arthur progresser et donc pour nous
c'était pas satisfaisante a une
obligation moyens et il y avait si je
devais synthétiser ça un jour à la
sortie de l'école il ya une maman qui a
dit
10 qui lui a dit vous devez être
contente d'avoir casé et c'était le
sentiment qu'on avait par rapport à ça
et nous on voulait pas caser notre
enfant on voulait lui donner les moyens
d'évoluer aujourd'hui ils sont sûrs
d'avoir fait le bon choix
malgré les sacrifices arthur vient
d'ailleurs d'apprendre à faire du vélo
voici maintenant le rêve d'un aventurier
vous le connaissez peut-être il
s'appelle bertrand piccard est le
nouveau défi qu'il s'est lancé de faire
le tour du monde dans un avion solaire
voyant comment il se prépare avec
nicolas chateauneuf et pascal stelletta
qui l'ont rencontré c'est un engin aux
formes étranges un drôle d'avion qui
vole grâce à l'énergie solaire au dessus
de la suisse aux commandes
andré borschberg le pilote est très
concentré ses moteurs viennent de
s'arrêter
il doit se poser en planant heureusement
quoi qu'il arrive il s'en sortir indemne
car andré borschberg est au coeur d'une
simulation hyperréaliste jusqu'au
moindre détail
tu pourrais me dire quelle est la
température sur le petit thermomètre
blanquette à droite derrière la
simulation l'aventurier bertrand piccard
et son équipe surveille le bon
déroulement du vol et le rythme
cardiaque tendre et chaque vol est une
épreuve physique pour les pilotes car le
tour autour du monde se fera par étapes
de 25 heures avec le simulateur alors
que l'avion lui-même et en pièces
détachées
ils peuvent déjà s'entraîner permet de
tester les capacités permet de tester la
résistance et permet aussi de voir
quelles sont les stats de fatigue dans
lesquels le pilote n'était plus assez
puis assez efficace et ça c'est très
intense jusqu'à maintenant on a vu que
se débrouillait tous les deux tout à
fait bien grâce au simulateur le
descends de l'avion a déjà été modifié
pour améliorer son efficacité et sa
maniabilité
l'objectif est de faire voler le
prototype d'une tonne 5 et de 61 mètres
d'envergure et ce uniquement avec
l'énergie solaire grâce à ces milliers
de capteurs situés sur l'immense elle si
tout va bien
le premier décollage cette fois ci bien
réelle aura lieu dans un an
sport football encore 24 heures
d'attenté 90 minutes de jeu nous serons
alors qui sera sacré champion de france
de ligue 1 tout cela c'est pour demain
soir on sort également qui devra l'an
prochain rejoindre la ligue 2 une chute
que redoute encore trois clubs paris
lens et toulouse le point et l'ambiance
comme on dit avec manuel tissier antoine
gaveau et olivier combe des pleurs il y
en aura demain soir des rires aussi
mais pas forcément sur les mêmes visages
que le 29 mars dernier
paris et lens finaliste de la coupe de
la ligue jouent leur place en ligue 1
dans un match à distance avec toulouse
avant la dernière journée de championnat
les trois clubs sont au coude à coude
avantage paris le plg est sûr de se
maintenir s'il bat sochaux à l'extérieur
mais paul le guen et ses joueurs auront
une oreille dans les autres stades tout
autre résultat qu'une victoire les
laisse à la merci de leurs poursuivants
ils vont pas non plus je veux avec une
oreillette il faut qu'il joue d'abord
qu'il faut qu'on cherche à gagner ce
match en priorité
et puis et puis après on tiendra informé
mais mais la priorité la priorité des
priorités c'est de faire le meilleur
match possible pour obtenir le meilleur
résultat possible
les lensois de jean pierre papin eux
vont jouer à domicile devant 35 mille
supporters mais ils doivent écarter
bordeaux pour rester en ligue 1 contre
le deuxième du championnat toujours en
course pour le titre les fans sang et or
semblent résignés pour moi c'est mal
barré
je pense que lens emma descendent et
certains joueurs que j'aimais bien genre
monterrubio
je veux le voir dernière fois parce que
comment l'esprit au duo kun hee square
toulouse paraît le mieux loti de ces
trois finalistes du bas de tableau
les toulousains reçoivent valenciennes
mais les nordistes ont annoncé qu'ils ne
se laisseraient pas bousculés et
toulouse n'a plus gagné chez lui depuis
six mois on a un bilan à domicile qui
est des catastrophiques à nou 2-2 en
arrachant du poids rattraper ça sur un
match nul de saisir notre chance
il y aura deux vainqueurs dans cette
lutte finale mais aucun trophée
fin du suspense dans vingt-six heures
le festival de cannes avec dans un
instant catherine deneuve et mathieu
amalric qui sont avec nous c'est
l'évènement de la soirée avec un film
français en compétition un conte de noël
film d'arnaud desplechin une histoire de
famille avec ses désordres que vous
dévoile marie-jo jouant et guillaume
michel ils sont venus en force
une quinzaine de comédiens pour le conte
de noël d'arnaud desplechin des stars et
des fidèles du réalisateur pour la
quatrième fois en compétition
catherine deneuve retrouve sa fille kara
dans ce film choral où elle joue la mère
d'une famille de conventionnel nouvelle
à vous annoncer
et enfin j'ai mes analyses il se trouve
que je suis compatibles tu vois sur mer
il n'y a que moi sur qui tu puisse
vraiment content
l'un de ses fils pas le préféré peut
sauver jules non la mer atteint d'une
leucémie elle doit trouver un donneur de
moelle potentiel par l'un des siens
on comprend vite que l'amour maternel ou
fraternelle ne sont pas des figures
imposées
c'est toujours filmé avec un tel amour
pour les personnages que moi je
on se méprend se passe pas au dessus
d'eux il n'y a pas de notion de morale
finalement c'est quand même des gens
vachement libre pas de nom d'ici sa
balance même pas mal façon jeu de
massacre tout de même toujours peint tgv
mais en plus je prends est entre bonnes
mains
ça passe aussi très forts à travers les
acteurs c'est pas ça à travers catherine
et mathieu c'est un plaisir énorme à ce
disque eu des joueurs woods jouera vers
un vrai plaisir à ne pas être d'accord
ou et houda des choses comme ça à ce
titi et à saint mathieu amalric face à
catherine deneuve
arnaud despléchin s'amuse aussi avec ses
acteurs mon bébé elle s'apprête après
quelques chants
la chambre audio dans un conte de noël
qui en rajoute la belle fille de
catherine deneuve
c'est la première fois qu'elle abîme
scène ensemble au cinéma ça me faisait
rire parce que l aime pas du tout ça
brûle la bruche donc moi même la pièce
rapportée
elle n'aime pas du tout c'est marrant
quoi alors poule de noël ou fable
cruelle
un peu des deux car on ne peut
s'empêcher d'être fasciné par cette
tribune bancal certes mais tellement
émouvante
alors le buzz comme on dit est bon le
film a semble-t-il touché la critique
avec nous donc catherine deneuve et
mathieu amalric bonsoir à tous les deux
merci d'être avec nous alors tout
d'abord catherine deneuve merci être au
coeur de cette journée toujours un peu
folle la journée de montée des marches
les premiers retours de la critique sont
bons ça fait du bien dans une journée
comme ça et côté pour me l'annoncer
j'ai pas eu le temps de lire les
critiques du jour donc j'étais heureuse
de savoir faire monter les marchés alors
un conte de noël c'est une histoire de
famille c'est un film de groupe et en
même temps on touche souvent l'intime de
chacun des personnages
ah oui oui je crois tous les personnages
sont même ceux qui ont l'air d'être plus
courts sont très fouillé ce sont des
sont tous des personnalités bien
différentes
on se dit des choses qu'on généralement
on ne se dit pas dans les familles c'est
assez c'est assez agréable d'ailleurs ça
fait du bien et chacun retrouvera un peu
denses dans cette histoire quelques
bribes peut-être des désordres de sa
propre famille oui en général je crois
que les gens retrouveront des choses
qu'ils n'ont jamais osé dire peut-être
dans son film on peut pas dire que votre
relation avec votre fils soit simple un
amour d amour avec ce fils qui
interpréterait par mathieu amalric
oui ça choque ça choque pas mal ça parce
que c'est vrai qu'en principe on pense
que la mouvement tenait à l'amour
maternel et qui n'est que
et que donc on doit élever ses enfants
il se trouve que je lui dis que je
n'aime pas on tous les cas c'est celui
que j'aime le mois et il me dit que lui
c'est pareil il va vous le dire lui-même
sauvé par la réciproque
oui mais c'est assez plaisant parce que
c'est pas le genre de choses qu'on pense
généralement de ses propres enfants ça
fait ça fait du bien ça permet de
libérer des choses violent je la cède
ensuite voit juste raconter linverse
certainement oui
la fin de laquelle on comprend que l'ont
finalement celle inverse quand même
alors mathieu amalric despléchin
stationné à ce que finalement vous
connaissez bien maintenant qu'est-ce qui
vous pousse toujours à dire oui à ces
propositions est précisément qu'est ce
qui vous a convaincu cette fois ci mais
j'ai pas le choix c'est lui qui a
inventé comme acteur j'étais pas du tout
prévu pour ça et c'est lui qui a pris le
risque de me faire jouer la première
fois ensuite on s'est retrouvés dix ans
après pour was even et il sentait s'y
trouve donc oui j'ai toujours pas fait
le film mon prochain film je vois là
catherine deneuve vous suivez vous dites
souvent vous suivez votre instinct ils
guident vos choix il vous a guidé vers
un documentaire sur le livre et son
titre c'est je veux voir je crois il est
en compétition pour un certain regard
on regarde un extrait on en parle juste
après
non là comme on a fait cette route n'est
pas sécurisée
on a préféré arrêter alors catherine
deneuve qu'est ce qui vous a intéressé
dans ce projet au liban c'était une
proposition qui décèdent par deux
artistes libanais qu'il voulait et si de
fixer en images la destruction de deux
du liban et comme le hezbollah
reconstruit très très vite rade et
reconstruit très vite il était très tenu
par le temps et nous en même temps les
détenus pour des raisons politiques et
on a eu un des sujets de passer entre
deux moments quand même très très
difficile je veux dire pour le liban et
moi c'était une façon d'exprimer plus
que ma sympathie pour ce pays que je ne
connaissais pas encore et qui est encore
au coeur de l'actualité
il est en compétition pour un certain
regard atteint un mot mathieu amalric
j'imagine que que cannes ça ressemble
pour vous à une grande machine interview
est ce qu'il y a aussi tout de même un
peu de plaisir à être là bas oui la
montée des marches et peut-être dans la
sortie de la salle quand une fois qui a
ses applaudissements des sens on est les
premiers à sortir et s'allume cette
cigarette en haut des marches qui a plus
de photographes ya juste le le tapis
rouge et on aimerait qu'il pas les
voitures et de pouvoir continuer à
marcher vers la mer et rêvasser
ce que les gens ont pu ressentir pour le
film rec ça va très vite
toute cette montée cette attente cette
province est la seule coupable le fait
fini donc il ya une respiration et puis
on ira peut-être à la fête alors en tout
cas belle fin de soirée et belle fête
j'espère pour vous
merci à tous les deux donc on suivra
bien évidemment ce film ce soir merci
encore à une interview réalisée juste
avant la montée des marches justement ce
soir un conte de noël un film coproduit
par france 2 avant de terminer ce
journal vous en rappelle l'une des
principales informations c'est la hausse
constante des prix du carburant la
colère des pêcheurs mais également celle
du consommateur depuis quelques jours le
prix du gazole dépassent parfois
d'ailleurs le prix de l'essence à la
pompe
aujourd'hui le baril de pétrole a battu
un nouveau record à new york
voilà pour l'actualité de ce vendredi
merci d'être fidèle à l'info sur france
2 demain je vous retrouve dès 13h pour
le journal magazine 13h15 dans un
instant la météo isabelle martinez suivi
du point route avec valérie maurice
20h50 soirée polar le septième juré avec
jean pierre darroussin passé une très
belle soirée et à demain j'espère
l'info en continu c'est aussi sur france
2 point fr